[Music]
in the first part we thought that force
is not just a human pushing or pulling
an object a force is a pusher pull upon
an object resulting from its interaction
with another object there are two things
we will cover in this video types of
forces and the effects of forces for
simplicity we can classify forces into
two types contact forces and non-contact
forces contact forces are just what they
sound like forces that results from the
interaction of two objects in contact
with each other after any contact forces
you know us asking you a few what
happens when you softly kick the ball
which is lying on the ground you apply
the force on the ball and there was
contact applied force is one of the
contact forces next there is a force of
friction which brings the ball to a halt
as the ball is in contact with the
ground the frictional force is also a
contact force don't you think there was
some air resistance yes a resistance to
is a contact force the normal force
which is applied force in the upward
direction if it contact forces well
these were some of the contact forces we
know of but these are not the only ones
can you think of any known contact force
what happens when the ball is in the air
it will fall down right what was the
ball down yes it's the gravitational
bulb which is trying to pull the ball
towards the center of the earth this
pull happens even if the object is not
in physical contact with the earth the
gravitational force is an example of a
non-contact force other examples of
non-contact forces are electrical and
magnetic forces
now I want you to think about the next
question I'm going to ask you what all
kind of force do what can be its effect
let me give an example a force can set a
stationary object in motion that's one
of the things force can do can you think
of the other things it can do assume an
object is moving at a uniform velocity
of two meters per second if it is push
harder its velocity will increase so
force can also change the velocity of an
object a force can also stop a moving
object anything else you can think of
yes
force can also change the direction of a
moving object if a ball is moving
towards the north a kid from the right
can change its direction to not west is
there anything else you can think of
force can do come on I want you to think
really hard don't think only in terms of
motion a force can also change the shape
of an object if we apply force from both
sides to a spherical ball its shape
changes the ball's position does not
change but its shape does so these are
some of the things that force can do in
the next video we will play an
interesting game to know if you really
understood how forces act on an object
[Music]